- Hi, I'm Patti Harrison
- No one likes you, and
I'm Joel Kim Booster.
- Is that true?
And you're watching Unsend,
where we celebrate the
best and worst of the web,
But mostly, the worst.
- So let's jump
right into Unsend.
- Come on everybody,
the water's fine.
(shooting noise)
- I'm already damp.
- You're nasty,
watch your volume.
(party music)
(cheering)
Our social media profiles really
define and brand who we are,
and what we want to
say to the world.
- And I got to say, you and
I are really differing on
queer, all body con
asian, egg roll.
- Futuristic,
ravishing, demonic,
laugh out loud piss,
shit, cum squirty squirty.
Yes, today our brand is
tight but was it always?
- That's why we're digging
into vintage socials
and asking the question:
- [Hosts] Defend or Delete?
(futuristic music)
- So first I'd like to
just start with this tweet
that you shot off
in 2015, "Sorry
"I only do butt stuff
with verifieds."
Like why did you
think this was okay?
- It was 2015.
I was a different person then.
I think I have a different point
of view now, I
wasn't verified then.
- Oh.
- I didn't know what
verified people were like. I
made a mistake I deeply regret
saying that, anything like that.
- 'Cause I guess my question is,
what did you think verified
people were like then?
'Cause you do know that you
can have like 400 followers
and write one article for
Huff. Post Queer Voices
and you can get
verified these days,
you know it's super easy.
- I thought verified people
were better and I still do.
- What's going on?
Is your Latisse
******* you up again?
- Yeah.
I can only say I'm
really sorry.
- So you would delete?
- I would delete.
So, Joel, we have
this first post here.
The caption says,
"It's not delivery,
"it's the $7 Digiorno
"that they put in
a microwave for me
"because we're all
trapped on this train
"and have no other options
"hashtag train life."
- There's a broader
context here,
I was trapped on an Amtrak train
from New York to
Chicago for 27 hours
and I didn't have any
other food options,
so I had to buy the
food on the train,
and so this is a comment on
capitalism and train life.
Again, it's funny.
- Joel.
- It's funny, I'm funny!
- Joel!
I don't think you
should delete it.
- Oh wow.
- [Patti] I agree with you.
- Thank you.
- And one thing that you
didn't actually talk on
that I thought was
pretty cool was that
you took this
this iconic
slogan from Digiorno,
it's not delivery,
it's Digiorno,
and you spun it in this
kind of academic way
where everyone was like,
- No, okay, I thought you were
on my side,
- [Patti] Reading it, and they
were like, it's not delivery,
- and now it's clear,
you're making fun of me.
- They think they know.
And look at this absolute fire
- And listen,
this was four years ago.
- Yes, it's the $7, oh my God,
and you're, oh my God, Joel.
- I know what
you're doing and I'm
gonna accept all of
that that you just said
at face value, because,
I am smart, and I'm good, and
I'm funny, and I'm worth it.
(electronic music)
- Death.
Stop, it's my own
personal religious belief
that dying is so bad.
But you know what's
the best, very good?
Seeing random celebrities
insert themselves
into a memorial of the deceased.
- That is fun.
- It's very good.
So let's take a
moment to comb through
social media condolences
and memorials
in a segment I call,
I Know Dead People
- Oh, my God.
(laughs)
That is so funny.
- Here we go.
Gonna start off with
my girl Kirstie Alley,
who gave us this
absolutely heart-wrenching
tribute to Stephen Hawking,
"You had a good go at it,
"thanks for your input."
- "Thanks for your input"?
Hawking is a world renowned
British theoretical physicist
known for his
contributions to the fields
of cosmology, general
relativity, and quantum gravity!
- Yeah, and
Kirstie's acting like
Stephen is her old nutritionist
who gently suggested
cutting back on dairy.
- Not a chance, bitch,
I love sour cream!
- Also, I'm going
absolutely wild crazy cuckoo
for this emoji-riddled
tweet from Cher to Stephen.
"Dear Stephen, will remember
our luncheon forever.
"It was amazing.
"I know we argued about
the value of history.
"'Cher, when time
travel is perfected,
"'history will obsolete.'"
- Then we get into the
latter part of the tweet,
which is rhymes and riddles
and a potpourri of punctuation.
History is like a friend, comma,
and new quotations,
hashtags are like
chicken emoji scratches to me,
shocked face emoji,
capitalized dyslexia,
RIP dear, cap the D, heart
emoji, no end quotes.
- Girl, pass me some of
what you are smoking,
this tweet is lit.
- Gross, okay?
Disgusting, it's too much.
- It is too much,
it's all too much.
So I'd like to call for
an end to this behavior.
- Oh, you mean,
tasteless posts about
celebrity deaths, or-
- No, death in general.
I'm against it.
It should be banned.
- Oh my God, Patti.
No, we can't,
we talked about this,
this is not a
political show, okay?
- Call your senators,
vote them out.
- Vote who out, the dead?
- We're here, we're queer,
and we'll never die.
We're here, we're queer,
- Let's talk movies,
because here's the thing.
We're millennials.
- We're young as ****.
- I'm so young my
skin is like a baby.
So we don't have 90
minutes to spare to watch
any old full ass feature film,
heck, we don't even have
time to watch a trailer.
- I don't even have
time to let you
finish your sentence, Joel.
- I got most of it out.
So let's review the
latest streaming releases
using a method of criticism
we can understand: our phones,
without doing any research.
- Okay, to be clear,
we're gonna review
movies based solely
on the thumbnail posters
of what's streaming online?
- Okay!
- Movies!
- Yeah!
- Yeah, movies!
- Movies.
- Yeah.
Okay, here we have Alright Now
with I believe that's
Cobie Smothers.
That's her name, right?
- Can't read it.
But what I can see is Miss Cobie
looking at me with her
smothering smolder.
And she's got a leather
jacket on, baby.
That can only mean
one thing, baby.
This lady stays unplain
and yells cuss words
and tells authority figures
to kiss her butt, baby.
I am frankly scared to death
of this maniac bitch, baby.
- No, thank you, she's got
a guitar in the background?
Swiping away!
Irrational Man, looks
like Joaquin Pheonix,
which, I gotta be honest,
I'm always surprised
when I remember he's alive,
not that I have anything
against Joaquin Pheonix,
it's just when I think
about him, I want him dead.
- True.
And Emma Stone, with
her eyes and rasp
and whimsy and wonder.
I like those qualities
in a leading gal.
- Same!
Okay, maybe we'll
give this one a-
oh shit.
Oh no.
Oh, dang it, Patti, dang it!
You see that font?
That old timey, jazzy font?
The signature font of an
accused child molester?
They just about tricked
us into watching
a Woody Allen joint!
- No thank you, no more
pedophile movie for me.
Okay, I'll have
nothing to do with
this trash titty movie, next.
- And now we've got
My Friend Dahmer.
Now, you know they've
already tickled my interests
because you know how
I love a movie poster
with one big head
looking this way
and then a little
head looking this way,
and then another head
looking this way.
- It's very powerful.
Plus they've got pinkish hues,
and a guy who looks
sad and misunderstood.
There's a sweetness to
this Jeffery Dahmer,
and I like that.
Also, his glasses
are chic as hell.
Who is that lady staring
at us underneath?
Guessing she's playing
his mother his-
- Oh my God, it's Anne Heche
I need this new series!
Stream this, rent
this, buy this,
put it in a sandwich
and put it in my mouth!
- You know I have a
gymnastics injury.
- I'm so sorry, forgot.
- Well, we did it.
- We sure did done do it.
- We did the ding daddy.
- Yup, that's the
end of our show.
- And it's the end of your life.
- Wait, uh, what?
- Nothing, thanks
for watching Unsend.
- Yeah, bye, can we-
- Oh no, I immediately
feel bad for doing that.